I am followed by fire it sounds really
really weird I know but it's true every
house every apartment I've ever lived in
was burned to the ground even stranger
it's predictable if I live somewhere for
six years six years after I move out it
goes up in flames it's not exact but
it's close usually accurate to within
two or three months it's true I'm not
sure when I noticed the pattern for the
first time but it's always been there
when I was just a kid right after I was
born my family lived in an old house
behind my grandmother's house we were
there until I was two when we moved I
remember visiting my grandmother's of
for watching the smoldering embers of
the little house and the curling smoke
rising into the air old wiring from the
50s finally gave out and the Shack we
moved to the farm
we weren't well-off enough to own it or
anything but we did run it for the local
doctor the farmhouse wasn't that big and
most of my childhood memories come from
the cozy family setting and engendered
here I remember Christmas Thanksgiving
birthdays I think of it whenever I think
of back home we lived there from when I
was two until I was nine
when the doctor we worked for died at
fifteen it burned an old tree struck by
lightning sparking off the blaze
the third house I lived in was the
second burned to the ground we only
lived there for around two years so it
happened when I was 13 it was an old
house a very old house what I remember
most was shape wood called them shotgun
houses because you could fire a shotgun
from one end and it would pass all the
way through to the other one room after
another all in a straight line built as
needed it was honestly very old and dry
I'm not surprised that the heating stove
in the front rooms bubbling on the
tenants after us other than where I'm at
now the only place left is my parents
current house when they asked me why I
was moving all my stuff stored in the
basement out I didn't have the heart to
tell them so I made up so excuse about
having my old books and stuff closer to
college I didn't know what else to say
when I turned 19 I moved out of my
parents house and went to college before
writing the house I live in now
I stayed in an apartment in the city I
shared it with a couple of [ __ ] it
seemed nice enough before I moved in
everyone knows the time won't pay their
bills on time eats whatever they could
lay hands on it got worse and worse
until I made up my mind when I finally
had enough I left we were four months
into a one-year lease now I'm just
keeping an eye on the news waiting for
the sparks a gas leak strain match
sooner or later
they'll burn they always burn
you